well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Thursday September the 26
2019 session in our series on
international technology management this
year our theme is about edge computing
I'm Richard Dyer I direct the US Asia
Technology Management Center and if you
believe that I started this series when
I was only three years old I can tell
you that we've been doing this series of
lectures for 27 years now we pick a
different theme every year and we
examine the newest kind of information
that we can get not only about work
that's being done here in some technical
area but also work that's being done in
Asia in some technical area so first of
all I'll talk a little bit about the
series itself and then kind of get into
edge computing and what that's all about
talk about the drivers of edge computing
adoption and then look a little bit at
upcoming sessions in this series so the
first biggest message is welcome to
everybody we're really happy that you're
here I know that this is not required
for anybody if you're a student and it's
wonderful to have a mixed audience of
people from inside Stanford and people
from outside Stanford one of the things
that I've always wanted as we've done
these series over the years is to have
more dialogue between these two groups
so that you get to know the industry
people and why they come to these
sessions and what things they're
interested in and conversely let's hear
from the student side how things look to
you and what kind of fresh ideas you
might have in regard to the general
topic of this of the of the series so
we'll be going every Thursday from now
until December the fifth we'll skip
Thanksgiving Thursday of course we are
an industry affiliates program that was
an electrical engineering for 25 years
and for the last two years has been
understand for global studies and the
School of Humanities
Sciences so we are interdisciplinary our
continuing mission is to introduce
trends and current developments in the
intersection of a particular area of
technology in business so these are not
serious technical presentations but
there is a lot of technology involved so
if you feel uncomfortable either because
there's too much technology or too
little technology you're in exactly the
right place we think that having a
discussion from both perspectives will
help everybody to understand what's
going on and find useful things for
yourselves so we do make special
reference to the US and Asia we have
some people coming in from Europe will
be speaking in the seminars but mostly
this is about us and Asia because of
kind of traditionally there's not as
much knowledge exchanged across the
Pacific as you would think
and we have the speaker slides and also
videos for the last at least six or
seven years of these programs up on the
web so if you're interested in a
particular topic run a search and you'll
likely find us for it oh yeah you can
see how these things go let's look at
edge computing which is really the next
major architectural stage in the
evolution of networked information
processing thanks to Microsoft for
having these cute
you know arrow shaped templates that you
can use really there are four stages
that I would say have occurred or are
occurring in this history of networked
information processing mainframe
terminal client-server cloud computing
and finally edge computing so to look at
these in a little bit more detail the
era the mainframe terminal goes way back
am I the only person in the
who remembers Wilbur anybody else
remember Wilbur that was Stanford's
mainframe and a lot of things were done
on Wilbur it was time access and so if
you really had a program that required
some number crunching you kind of had to
do it in the middle of the night so the
clients were really dumb terminals the
first computer I ever had even a PC you
couldn't display graphics on the PC you
had to buy a special graphics card the
connectivity was by a private custom
network on timeshare and that meant that
the software for these systems were not
compatible with each other I worked for
a Japanese company in the early 1990s
and with a company with only 50 people
in it we had our own mainframe computer
because nobody had a PC the mainframe
did financial processing it did
personnel records it did you know the
basic forms and kind of stuff but there
was absolutely no compatibility between
our computer and our customers computer
so you know that was the way things
started out notice how you had people
who are doing data processing right the
second stage was really when the
engineering workstation came along and
engineering workstations were very
powerful individual desktop units that
could do a lot of things and if you
could network them together you could
communicate you could do group projects
you could do all kinds of things I
remember when I first got to Stanford in
McCullough building I helped run
Ethernet cable under the ceiling or on
top of the ceiling to link the different
computers in our own little network so
at that point in the early part of this
era which was really around 19
it was mostly workstations and a few pcs
and later you had PCs workstations and
also peripherals printers and so forth
on the client side and during this era
internet protocol took over so that
pretty soon the definition of a network
was not what kind of protocol you were
using it was basically some sort of you
know firewall or something else the
standardization of the application
software could happen at this point this
was the era of the wind hell monopoly
right Windows and Intel and things like
whatever could run on the client
especially in the later stages Microsoft
Word Microsoft Outlook Microsoft
whatever and the intensive processing
intensive applications would still run
on the server somewhere the server would
also access to things like a central
database and so forth near the end of
that era so from dumb terminals with all
the processing in the mainframe suddenly
have a lot of processing happening out
on the client-side and some processing
being done inside the server that's kind
of unifying the group along about the
time the smartphone came along this
evolved into the era of cloud computing
and what happens in cloud computing is
you have all sorts of different client
types with various levels of
intelligence probably smartphones and
PCs are still the dominant ones but
you've got tablets you've got mp3
players you've got sensors you've got
smart appliances coffee cups movie
tickets anything can be connected to
this cloud now and really Internet
Protocol is by far the dominant thing
that is being used to connect the
clients into the internet and really a
local area network is nothing more
and some sort of a secure position on
the Internet
most of the processing has gone into the
cloud what happens is that a copy of the
devices operating system and the
application it's trying to run will go
into some server in some data center
through a process called virtualization
and so there will be a virtual machine
meaning a copy of the client inside the
data center that will be where all of
the actual processing in the application
happens this is efficient because you
can have three million cell phones all
connected up and and you know however
many different operating systems you can
have 99 percent capacity use on your
servers instead of running every single
one of those 3 million devices and
dependently
so it's a much more efficient way to
handle the processing power efficient
and so forth some interesting things the
legal system still hasn't figured out
how to deal with some aspects of this if
you are infringing somebody else's
copyright where do you sue the person do
you see the person where the client is
or do you sue the person where the
server is
because the server may be in Finland and
if you're trying to engage in real
severe political kind of whatever legal
issues like that in some countries you
can remove the physical server from the
data center if you can identify it in
other countries you cannot so the legal
system still hasn't caught up with cloud
computing but this is where we are now
we have hit the era of cloud computing
full-on - back in 2016 so three years
ago there was a survey of almost a
thousand IT professionals
that were conducted yearly and in the
2016 survey about 72% of them said that
their company was using at least one
cloud application by 2018 that number
had gone up to 96% so it's ubiquitous
what kind of things are being done in
the cloud email of course Gmail is a
cloud application all you're doing is
the reading and inputting on your device
all of the processing of the emails are
happening in some data center somewhere
Stanford's email system is the same way
you have other things that are very you
know useful thing customer relationship
management voice over Internet Protocol
human resource management helpdesk kind
of thing the interesting thing about
these particular areas this shows how
many what percentage of companies in
their sample are actually using the
cloud four of these different business
functions and the middle sized companies
companies between 500 and a thousand one
hundred and five hundred employees
actually have a higher use of the cloud
than do the big companies partly because
the big companies have their own private
set ups and they don't need these
standard applications that are provided
by some third-party vendor now we get to
the edge so you've still got this kind
of cloud in the middle and what's
happening is that there's a lot of
intelligence in the devices at the edge
in the clients at the edge you've got in
addition to smartphones which continue
to become more and more like miniature
computers
you've got connected cars you've got
airplanes doing a lot of information
processing being connected you have
drones you have networked robots and for
the things that are less
intelligent sensors in the smart factory
you will have some sort of an edge
server or a gateway server or a micro
data center out near the edge and in
regard to connectivity what you're
seeing is integration of really
high-speed mobile access as well as
fixed network access so our our
presentation next week is by Professor
Paul Raj on 5g networks and really from
5g you cannot tell the difference
between mobile and not mobile so you
it's interesting how this is basically
an optimization problem where some
applications you really want to run them
at the edge because it takes too much
time too many nanoseconds for the
electric signal to get to the data
center and be processed in the data
center and get back now that sounds kind
of hard to imagine but if you're running
a self-driving car you really don't want
the data to go all the way to the data
center and back before you in order to
avoid some obstacle so really it's a
continuing optimization one of the
things that's happened in IT is with the
in the spread of artificial intelligence
there's this need for huge amounts of
data to process some problems especially
in business analytics so business
analytics tend to be closed done closer
to the cloud whereas the real-time
applications navigating your drone tend
to happen more out at the edge you get
rid of all the latency involved in going
back and forth to some data center some
some you know thousands of miles away
it's important to remember that edge
computing does not replace cloud
computing so unlike the client-server
era in the mainframe era the mainframe
era kind of
pretty much declined although you can
still buy mainframe IBM computers I
think but really edge computing is sort
of an add-on to the cloud computing
structure you'll see this processing at
the edge for some things I just
mentioned and processing that requires a
lot of data or heterogeneous data from
various sources will tend to be done
more in the cloud you'll also hear the
term fog computing and fog is typically
this sort of micro datacenter range in
between the edge devices and the cloud
so if you think of a rack of servers
typically they will define a micro data
center is anything with less than five
racks of servers this is in the fog and
again it's an optimization problem how
do you get the processing done in the
most efficient way possible
so why is this happening first of all
the amount of data generated is just
exploding I've got a couple of slides on
that and a lot of the data that's being
created like this real-time data as your
self-driving car is running down the
road is so transient it doesn't make
sense to store it in a data center at
all keep it at the edge deal with it
there there's this huge demand for
inform or real bail date real-time data
processing concerns about privacy and
security actually kind of drive edge
computing it's really hard to share
medical data between one hospital and
another and if you're doing an analysis
of data using the cloud what happens is
the data that you have on your edge
device whether that's a computer or a
little mainframe or a little data center
inside your company at the edge is going
to be cop
into some database a new file right into
some database in the data center where
it will be put along with a lot of other
data for the analysis that process of
copying increases the security risk and
so the HIPAA regulations in the u.s.
make it really difficult to do that
so this argues for doing more analysis
of the data at the edge and we've got a
company coming in in a few weeks that
has a really interesting solution to how
to combine data from lots of different
hospitals in an analysis but have the
data analyzed inside each of the
hospitals not inside the center in the
cloud another thing that's really
driving the growth of edge computing is
a new life in the semiconductor industry
so most of the computer chips in the
data centers in the big racks and the
data centers are either CPUs or GPUs
graphic processing units so NVIDIA has
made tons of money selling GPUs into the
data center and this is fine there are
multi-purpose chips though and so if you
can design a single purpose or an
application-specific chip right an ASIC
you can usually make it run even faster
and with less power consumption which
means it's great for edge devices so
this kind of new wave of computer chips
is also driving the growth of edge
computing we will have a presentation in
two weeks from the director of AI
marketing from Intel who is a good
friend and so I'm glad that we can have
this coming up - yeah this explosion of
data look what is going into the central
cloud back in the old days it was all
form based what the
the technical term is structured data
and then you have blogs and social media
click-through data and so forth that the
technical term is unstructured data
along about 2015 there was more sound
files and video files floating around
the internet than there were text files
that was a major kind of turning point
and it's not all Netflix a lot of it is
thanks to Alexa and Syrian and this
group but we're really right at the
early ages of you know a lot of Internet
of Things data sensor data connected
smart devices robots everywhere each
time you have a new type of data coming
in you have to reconfigure your
analytics to be able to deal with it
there's a lot of really interesting
company start up companies out there now
that are bringing in new types of data
to very old problems so there was a
company what is the name of this company
zest financial I think that has the
ability to look at lots of different
kinds of data including how long it
takes you to fill out the form that they
put in front of you and your if you're
applying for credit and so they have a
huge joint partnership with the Chinese
e-commerce company JD comm now that
allows extension of credit for
e-commerce to people who are unbanked
they've never had a bank account they
don't have a credit card and so this is
kind of the new thing that you're
getting by using these new data types
but as this new data comes online one of
these graphs right for the exponential
increase in the amount of data that is
created now just to give you an idea of
what they're really talking about if a
gigabyte was the size of one brick a
zettabyte
would be the size of the Great Wall of
China so around 2010 there was a little
over one zettabyte of data that was
created during the entire year by the
year 2025 the prediction is that there
will be more than 160 zettabytes of data
created and during that particular year
some of it will be stored long-term a
lot of it won't one of the interesting
things about this is that the real-time
data is going up like crazy about 40 or
45 zettabytes of real-time transient
data is predicted to be created in the
year 2025
so one of the problems with this kind of
new IOT data is that it's unpredictable
if you have a fire or an explosion or
something unusual happening all of the
sensors in the factory may go haywire
and fire off all at once so suddenly you
give this huge spike in the amount of
data that you've got that's a challenge
for you know processing of the data and
so the real-time data the closer you can
keep it to the edge the better it will
be how much money are we talking about
follow the money right so I looked at
five different market research reports
on edge computing and just for
comparison I looked at three other
market research reports on cloud
computing all of these were published
this year
none of them are older than 2019 but
they would look at you know four of the
four of the five edge computing ones
started off in the year 2018 one of them
started off in 2019 and you see a wide
range of predictions for how big the
edge computing market is going to be in
the year twenty four twenty twenty four
twenty twenty five you see quite a wide
range in the cumulative annual growth
rates
that are predicted by these numbers but
if you'll notice some things about this
notice how much bigger first of all the
cloud computing market is than the the
edge computing market so edge computing
is still almost a subset of cloud
computing they're not directly
contiguous be careful they're there
they're pulling their data in different
ways but if you have a cloud computing
market of somewhere around 700 billion
dollars a year that's twice the size of
the semiconductor industry that's really
about half the size of the entire retail
industry in the world and so it's you
know this is huge huge amount of money
and quite respectable growth rates that
are interesting to venture capitalists
right when you get over 25% of the V so
you start to pay attention go ahead
these were independent market research
reports so each one of these market
research reports and these have nothing
to do with these ok they're separate
reports yeah and one reason that that's
an important point is because there are
so many differences in how they
calculate and forecast the size most of
those are definition differences are
they looking in the narrow sense at just
edge computing services as opposed to
other cloud computing services or are
they looking at a broader definition
that would include some of the growth of
related technology businesses so for
example 5g networks which we're going to
talk about some more are predicted to be
a huge market what's the overlap between
the market research predicted for 5g and
the market research predicted
for edge it's probably quite a big
overlap the two are really going to grow
in tandem with each other and really
some of the cost of a connected car is
going to be related to the data transfer
problem the edge computing problem yeah
most cars have a lot more information
processing power than my old PC did back
in the year 1982 so some of the value of
the cars that are going to be sold of
the energy systems that are going to be
delivered will come from the computing
power should that be included in the
definition of what they're measuring it
varies from company to company but
consistently across you see how big
cloud computing is and you also see that
the growth rates predicted for edge
computing are higher than the growth
rates predicted for cloud computing
that's another kind of important
indication that edge computing is
becoming more and more important to the
world as we know it so if you turn this
into practical use cases what are we
talking about
first thing smart buildings if you do a
search on Internet of Things IOT it
seems to me that 80% of what I'm seeing
coming through the news now is all about
devices for the home you know smart
thermostats or smart speakers or
whatever but there's also not only homes
but factories warehouses I could have
said hospitals smart manufacturing
process control is also an edge
computing function
you've got the self-driving cars that
people talk about all the time when they
talk about edge computing drones
airplane systems connected car services
these are the services besides actually
running the car but how you're going to
have location-based advertising and so
forth
mobile augmented reality networked
gaming is going to be a driver of
e-commerce and things like Amazon go
register 'less stores that information
is being calculated somewhere some of
it's being calculated on your edge
device your cell phone and other is
going into some sort of a local server
healthcare monitoring wearable medical
devices part of this is the security and
privacy issue and part of it is the fact
that that's real-time data if your heart
is starting to do strange things you
don't want to hear about it three hours
from now
physical security and surveillance
systems we'll see some examples of these
especially when we look at what's going
on in Asia energy systems telemedicine
agricultural systems control twenty
years ago NASA and Stanford had a really
interesting joint project on telesurgery
the networks just weren't ready for it
then now you're really getting to the
point where you could probably have
telesurgery
where the actual data transfer time to
go thirty thousand kilometers to a
synchronous orbit satellite is too long
to have the surgery being managed up in
the cloud somewhere by the satellite
right so you want to do it at the edge
and maybe virtual assistants and I put
this up because I'm really not sure just
how much of your conversation with Alexa
is happening locally and how much I was
happening in the data center certainly
she's getting her information in the
data center right she's doing her
analysis back in the data center but the
actual processing of you know
text-to-speech the actual understanding
of what you're saying to her I'm not
sure how much of that stun at the edge
and how much Ivan's done in
the clouds anybody no okay we'll leave
that one find out see if we can find out
go ahead with all the assistance that
privacy consider right great thank you
that's thanks very much great to have
that so the second half of what I wanted
to talk about today was the kind of
regional perspectives what's going on
why are we doing this series with the
question mark different directions for
the US and Asia
first of all edge computing has
definitely hit the asian IT world some
of these market research reports are
predicting Asia to have the highest
growth rate of edge computing of any
region in the world and a lot of people
in Asia say that edge will be important
there was a survey done a couple of
years ago by this company of almost
10,000 people about 25 percent of them
were executives 25% were IT
professionals 25% were other business
people in Asia and I forget I think the
other 25% might have been independent
consultants but in Southeast Asia and
North Asia and Australian New Zealand
62% had plans to start edge computing
projects within the next three years and
97% of them had plans or said that edge
computing would be a relevant part of
their business or IT strategy beyond the
three-year limit so does that kind of
look a little bit like this
cloud computing graph that we
this one we're in 2016 you had 72% of
the companies had a cloud application
and now you've got 96% so it's very much
a few years behind cloud but definitely
going in the same direction Asia has
been deploying a lot of really
interesting edge computing projects some
of them in China involve a test bit or
are things like a testbed in Ken Jun for
video optimization and security
monitoring China Telecom has this smart
parking project in Yunnan and in Greedo
and there's actually a similar project
in Taiwan that's being sponsored by a
different telecom company one
interesting thing about those two
examples next week we're going to talk
about 5g networks and regulation in
China divides up the responsibilities of
mobile versus fixed for communications
so China Telecom is the the fixed
telephone company right the old wireline
group and China Unicom was the mobile
communications company suddenly they're
in each other's turf and so it'll be
interesting to see how the Chinese
government angles that I would say that
Baidu's Apolo platform which is a
technology development and also
operation platform for self-driving cars
is a good example of an edge computing
project taiwan has got this smart
streetlight system there's a nice
photograph of this you can find on the
internet so this is actually in
operation now where to save power
they've got edge computing going on in
each of the streetlights this spring
South Korea announced the world's first
5g enabled autonomous vehicle test bed
which is actually a district
regular streets so normal people are
driving through this area - it's not a
closed track and this was they claimed
to be the first one in the world they
have said that they're going to build
out their nationwide 5g network by next
year so I'm hearing not only government
investments involved in this the this
this project is actually run out of hon
Young University although it has
government money behind it and a lot of
company money behind it - but I'm
hearing that the Korean big companies
like Samsung and and Eun Dae and so
forth SK KT are planning on investing
upwards of 20 billion dollars in edge
computing in the next few years
maybe that's because the Japanese had
said that they're going to put 14.4
billion into it Japan was a little bit
behind and so they came to the table
late but they're definitely trying to
move forward with these major
investments and DoCoMo also has one of
these projects that's looking for video
analytics to be done on surveillance
cameras yeah we'll see how that goes
with the data privacy issues - now what
about the different directions the
reason that I really started to put this
series together was over the last couple
of years I'm watching this process of
decoupling between the US and China and
so what's going to happen right a lot of
the things are in the news there are
restrictions on US firms from buying
equipment or selling hardware software
to a certain list of companies that the
government maintains that are considered
national security concerns Huawei and
ZTE were put on the entity list but then
they have kind of temporarily been
removed off of it
and so what happened as a result while
we developed their own operating system
and the reports about this Huawei
operating system for cell phones that I
see is that it really is very different
from Android which is what they used to
use Huawei and Alibaba have both
announced their own AI processing chips
the interesting thing about alibaba's
chip is they don't plan to sell it it
will only be used for company internal
applications the US administration is
putting pressure on firms to move their
manufacturing back to the US so that's
happening some but it's also moving
manufacturing out of China and into
Vietnam so this is one of the things
where the global supply chains are
definitely realigning and there's a lot
tighter monitoring and control of
foreign investment inside the United
States - Lee wrote AI superpowers has
his investment firms in ovation and
Sinha vation appears to have pulled out
of American investments now it's kind of
questionable as to whether this is
serious and permanent or whether the
person who is here in Silicon Valley has
just kind of gone home for a while but
clearly their investment portfolio has
moved much more toward China than and
out of here they do have investments in
about 40 companies here and so somebody
is still taking care of them a couple of
some acquisitions by Chinese companies
have been blocked some Chinese investors
have been ordered to divest from their
US investments and so not surprisingly
look what happened from Chinese foreign
direct investment in the u.s. from 46
billion dollars in the year 2016 we are
now down to one tenth of that 4.8
billion dollars in 2018 so as the money
doesn't come the systems may get more
and more different the ecosystems may
get more and more different and it's not
only the US administration
China is also focusing more domestically
things like the indigenous innovation
policy things like the made in China
2025 which has kind of been backpedaled
by the Chinese government
are definitely aimed at doing more
things independently and not having
connections to the way the technologies
are developing here there's a new set of
cybersecurity policies coming online in
China and that November I think and they
appear to have kind of special targeting
of foreign firms okay well what goes
around comes around if we do that with
investors that's going to happen on the
other side of the Pacific and Chinese
regional influence is increasing I was
very shocked to find that trade between
China and the rest of the indo-pacific
region is twice as much as the trade
between China between the u.s. and the
indo-pak region so China accounts for
24% of exports from indo-pak and the
u.s. accounts for 12% of exports from
indo-pak now a lot of this these two
bullets had to do with components being
made in one Asian country and being
shipped to China for final assembly and
then they would go to some other market
well what's happening is the some other
market is no longer the US and Europe
its domestic China so you're really
seeing a major difference in the way
business is being done the regional
cooperation economic partnership I think
that's what that stands for is still
going on the negotiations are still
continuing China this is China's answer
to the TPP the trans-pacific partnership
which the u.s. pulled out off as soon as
our current administration started so
Japan is Japan and Australia have tried
to keep the TPP going it does not
include China but in some ways I think
the artis RCEP that does include China
is more active at the moment you're
getting a lot of investments from China
into Southeast Asia so this made a lot
of news when dd2 shing and Softbank put
two billion dollars behind the
ride-hailing company in singapore grab
but i was fascinated to find out that
chinese venture capital investments in
asean startup companies increased four
times four hundred percent in the first
half of this year to an astounding
amount of money six hundred and sixty
seven million dollars u.s. that probably
is because of a few mega deals big deals
that are more than 100 million each but
it's still an amazing increase and the
belton Road is still alive and well
they've gone up in there Southeast Asia
investments by twice as much in the
first half of this year over the second
half of last year so yeah China's
regional influence is increasing
although the people who do business in
Southeast Asia point out that Japan
still has a lot more influence there
than China does and a lot of the big
Japanese companies are trying to do
corporate venture capital and trying to
become more actively involved with the
growth of the middle class in Southeast
Asia so this is what's it going to do to
edge computing right this is the
question yeah go ahead in Thailand and
Vietnam and Malaysia and in that regard
it's a little different from world
patterns of investment into Southeast
Asia where most of that is going into
Singapore and the second to Singapore is
Indonesia on a worldwide level
go ahead thank you by the US government
of the long term medication that would
connect Asia to Africa involving many
many many nations prevention of Chinese
domination of technology most bringing
through this I think one belt one road
did shake up a lot of people and made a
lot of people concerned whether this is
purely emotional you know we've got to
contain China if you're Chinese that's
what it looks like they're they're just
trying to keep our economy from growing
they're trying to keep us from having
the influence that would naturally come
with the world's biggest economy if
you're in the u.s. though you worry
about the national security aspects of
someone who is not necessarily an ally
having more influence around the world
than you do so I don't know I think an
American would argue back that it's not
aimed at containment but that it is
aimed at meeting our national security
needs okay but yeah this is this is one
of the big problems with this is it is
it looks very different in the two
different places and I think that what
you can say for sure is that unless we
have some things to do together then the
two systems are just going to go further
and further apart now my take on that no
matter which side you want to follow in
this
is that the ultimate losers are probably
consumers because when you have a small
number of extremely large companies
controlling the market and over there
it's you know b80 Baidu Alibaba $0.10
maybe put in huawei - right and over
here it's either Fang or fog or whatever
you call it Facebook Amazon Google and
and whoever Netflix people have less
choices so if you really do have world
competition normal consumers should have
more choices and that should be better
for everybody that's the that's the way
it looks right yeah it is that's exactly
right
now again people have very impassioned
views for both sides and I don't really
need to get into that in this series
just recognize that these are the
consequences you're going to face right
so how's this gonna play out it now you
know in in edge computing as I stand
here in front of you I've got to say I
don't know that's why we're doing this
series and so I can bring in people who
I think will bring us information from
different aspects of the edge computing
world that might enlighten us as to what
kind of emerging trends are beginning so
next week I'm really happy that
Professor Paul Raj can come and speak to
us about five g 5g fifth generation
mobile fifth generation communications
networks are really a huge enabling
factor for edge computing but the amount
of infrastructure and investment is
staggering because of differences in
frequency you have to put the towers for
antennas for a 5g system a lot closer
together than you do
for what we have now for G five times as
many base stations space station towers
for a 5g network so this is a huge
amount of investment that's going to be
required to bring in 5g it's one of
these key technologies that the US has
been concerned about and one of the
reasons that it's it's definitely being
treated treated as one of these national
kind of security implication
technologies and professor Paul Raj is
not only an expert who has been on the
faculty at Stanford for a long time and
won the Marconi prize
he's an active consultant consultant the
industry and adviser to foreign
governments and I promised him I
wouldn't say who but he's talked to a
lot of these countries about adopting 5g
technology so I'm hoping he'll address
this next week two weeks from now we've
got Gary from Intel who's going to talk
about these chips for processing AI
functions gary was with a startup
company named mo videos that had an AI
acceleration device and they were bought
by Intel they are going to definitely
Intel Intel is is is really at the front
of a lot of these new initiatives that
are related to edge computing and Gary
can tell tell us about them he has
worked in Japan for many years he has
also a good you know kind of grasp of
Japanese language in you in addition and
so it'll be interesting to get his
international perspectives on the 17th
we've got dr. biker who used to run the
cars lab at Stanford he was the
executive director of cars lab and dr.
Martin C R Hui who is the head of
Alliance innovation lab
Nissan right used to be the Nissan
Research Center but because Nissan and
Renault are having such good relations
with each other
they changed the name anyway they'll
talk about edge computing and autonomous
vehicles then on the 24th we have our
speaker about medical data federated
learning is this approach where instead
of copying the data into the data center
the data center has what they call the
global state of some algorithm the
processing engine and it will choose
which of the edge devices typically
computers in this case it will send for
a sample right you've got to pick your
sample anytime you're going to do an
analysis for AI and it sends the
algorithm to the edge devices where the
processing is done and then once those
edge devices do the processing they send
the updated algorithm back to the center
where it creates a new global state
algorithm it's a really clever approach
instead of moving the data around you
move the algorithm around this is a term
that you will hear used a lot from
Google Google I think may be responsible
for the term but in any case we've got a
real use case for it this is a startup
company and they are actually using this
for medical data analysis on the
thirty-first we've got two people coming
to talk to us from the tiny ml ml
machine learning consortium and I'm
delighted that they can talk to us
because this is also how do you get the
operating system and the overhead on the
edge devices down as small as possible
so that you can do artificial
intelligence processing at the edge so
that'll be an interesting session on the
seventh we've got the co-founder and CEO
of Greene
roster which is basically a platform
company platform technology company for
the mobile gaming and mobile interactive
other noble interactive application
industries yeah and then on the 14th of
November we'll have a session live from
Tokyo I will be in Tokyo Japan
and interviewing dr. Ken Amato who's the
chief scientist for a little startup
company called leap mind that was
strongly recommended to me by a large
Japanese company our and so they have
done a proof-of-concept
with this big Japanese company on how to
use artificial intelligence to control
doors on subway trains and if you've
ever been on the subway in Japan you
know how hard it is and people are
always squeezing in at the last second
if you can save a second in closing the
door more efficiently than before the
whole system just explodes it's the
equivalent of taking one tomato out of
the salad on every airplane meal and
saving five million dollars as a result
so anyway he'll he'll speak I am talking
with a speaker about the 21st but I'm
not going to go any further on that we
don't have class on Thanksgiving and
then for the last session in the series
I'm really happy that dr. yoky Matsuoka
has agreed to come into a fireside chat
and talk about how she sees edge
computing developing she has a wonderful
perspective in this she was the CTO of
nest the home energy management company
she is a robotic specialist she really
developed the robotic arm and yeah so
it'll be great to have her come up and
wrap up the series so that's really what
I wanted to tell you about today this is
what we have coming down the pike it's
like a few minutes if you have questions
or comments go ahead yeah you see terms
like Cold War and a lot of the press
reporting about this kind of technology
divergence
I actually saw I think it was Hank
Paulson who is a really well-known kind
of economist journalist who said that
you know the result of this decoupling
and that's I think what the
administration calls it could be the
equivalent of an economic Iron Curtain
we're just you know people on that side
have their economy and on our side we
have ours that's true and I think that
both sides have a point in some ways
right because we do have to look at
national security I will say my own
personal opinion China is going through
economic development very rapidly and a
lot of what I see now kind of reminds me
of Japan in the 1980s and Japan had
reached the stage of being an advanced
economy but it kept some of the old
developing economy policies and customs
going on and so the country needed to
change and Japan did a lot of the change
by itself the big difference is that
Japan was totally dependent on America
for security and recognized itself as an
American
whereas no one can argue that the
economy of China will eventually be
four-year four times as big as the
American economy there's that many
people if their income levels approach
those in America the economy will be
much bigger and so I do think that you
have to consider your national interests
but is it a zero-sum game I mean again
on personal interest would be to go back
to more rules based kind of discussions
to have international organizations like
the World Trade Organization handle a
lot of the trouble but that's you know
here we are we're moving in this
direction what's going to happen I saw
one back in the back maybe that the less
developed infrastructure in developing
countries would encourage edge solutions
to be found first even before you come
up with some cloud-based solution and
certainly you know you've seen that leap
frogging over and over again mobile
communications jumped in developing
economies because they didn't have to
string copper wire throughout the
country and then the next thing is that
you're seeing mobile applications like
mobile banking much further ahead in
developing countries where people didn't
have an alternative this is satisfying a
basic need that before they didn't have
a way to deal with so yes that's that's
a very good point it's a very good
possibility who's going to do it so
that too I'm not sure I want to go into
Kai fuli's model of the US and China or
the two superpowers when it comes to
artificial intelligence or technology I
think it will be a lot more interesting
than that at least I hope it will be and
I hope we can have more
cross-pollination thank you good good
question
go ahead so what you're talking about
are things like requiring data on
citizens to be stored inside the country
and Indonesia went down that path it
this is one of the big things that were
discussed in the TPP negotiations I
think that edge computing will probably
take a little of the pressure off of
that the thing is the clouds not going
to go away though and so if you're doing
something like business analytics you
really want to have as big a body of
data to analyze as as possible and so I
really kind of wonder if if it's the
solution of the problem I don't think
it's the solution of the problem but it
might take some of the pressure off for
a little bit thank you other questions
comments so one of the features that we
have in this series is that we always
have refreshments at least I hope
they're out there after the session and
we want to encourage everybody to hang
around and get to know each other and
and yeah so thanks for coming today and
look forward to seeing you again next
week
[Applause]